at title tonight what hope for the
economy the crisis of capitalism and how
to deal with it we have about an hour
and 40 minutes to answer that question
and that we hear quite a lot about
crises and some of it is not always
clear I think I heard a friend Eric
Hobsbawm on Newsnight suggesting we are
running out of work I at the same time
here people we're running out of welfare
running out of government and public and
private services surely both can't be
true you hear people talk of China and
the shifting balance of power in the
world as a crisis for the West although
in some specs we should probably think
of that as being one of the great
successes of the modern era but it's
absolutely clear we are at a difficult
and interesting juncture and we're all
over the place in terms of making sense
of it so let's see if we can make sense
of it tonight now the proposal is we
divide this into three sessions will
have some panel discussion and then
we'll open up to the floor and then
we'll go back to the panel for a sort of
a second section come back to the floor
so what are the three sections that we
might divide this complicated topic into
first of all the macro economic crisis
which really deals with the fact that we
are in a recession depression rather
flatlining economy not just in the UK
but in the West we thought Keynes had
cracked the problem of how you get out
of that kind of situation but with
public debt debt levels as high as they
are it turns out to be more complicated
than that or does it so everything to do
with macroeconomics will be the sort of
first subject tonight we'll talk about
austerity and growth will talk about
global or UK rebalancing whether we have
the tools to do the job and whether we
are ready for the to use them the second
chunk which might I think be quite a
substantial one is what I would call the
micro
crisis about the functioning of our
economy not about the interest rates and
fiscal policy and monetary policy but
about the way our markets function or
dysfunction does the financial sector
for example serve the economy well or
badly just to take a random example in
some respects the real crisis of
capitalism it could be argued is that
business models have been allowed to
succeed which have failed business
models failed business models have been
allowed to succeed and people who
contribute rather little have been able
to take big returns lastly and perhaps
most interestingly the third section is
the eurozone crisis now this one is
special it's like the climax of one of
those endurance game shows where it gets
harder as you go along like gladiator
and it all hinges at the end on the last
round and the euro crisis is like that
because it combines the other two crises
we've talked about clearly there's a
macro economic crisis of coping with
austerity at the same time as wanting
growth at root in the eurozone we have
the micro economic crisis because in
some respects it was the functioning of
the banks that allowed debt imbalances
to accumulate and then at the same time
just to make it all the more exciting
policymakers have taken away all the
tools of flexible economic management
that you might have had at your disposal
for dealing with those problems like
exchange rates German fiscal policy and
central banking so that's if you like
where we'll finish we'll start we'll
sort of cope with nijah the eurozone
crisis at the very end so let me briefly
introduce the panel and we'll get get
down to business I've start at that end
thomas frank american journalist
historian author of a forthcoming book
pity the billionaire which as I
understand it Thomas sir suggests the
right have pulled off a fast one really
in getting the blame for the current
woes directed at governments rather than
at other more suitable culprits I think
you started out as a college republican
didn't you and you switched you're not
seen as that now
next to Thomas is Diane coil I should
say by the way I'm actually gonna
introduce each of them by book titles
it's it's just a sort of way of doing it
i won't give their bits v's i'll just
tell you their latest book Diane coil
economist and managing director of
enlightened tech nomics and author of
the economics of enough how to run the
economy as if the future matters next to
Diane Sir Martin Jacob a person for whom
the phrase City grandi was invented
chairman of the Canary Wharf group
utility on 2011 former chairman of
Barclays dizi wed and prudential and had
been on the court of the Bank of England
as well for some years I'm afraid to
Martin actually hasn't written a book as
I really have you written a book Barton
but I think Martin's anyone hasn't got a
book to peddle here tonight next to
Martin Anatole koletzki who's the
principal economic commentator of the
times who not so long ago wrote
capitalism 4.0 would set out some
principles for the capitalism that would
follow from capitalism 2.0 and 3.0 which
were the Keynesian and more thatcherite
versions principles in that book next to
an atoll is John Kay economists ft
columnist author of quite a few books
the truth about markets among them and
another one with a very long title about
finance finance for the intelligent
laymen were not in the industry you
don't have to remember all of it to find
it on Amazon next to john is stephen
king who is group chief economist at
hsbc stevens recent book was called
losing control the emerging threats to
Western prosperity and it was scary
enough for in fact for this Stephen King
to be confused with the other sea became
the horror writer and next to Stephen we
have Linda you cannot miss broadcaster
economics editor a bloomberg TV a fellow
at Oxford as well and co-authored
macroeconomics which I believe is a
recommended textbook for the UK
government economic service read into
that what you will and is also author of
a co-author of the economy of China
globalization and economic growth in
China and right at the end Gideon Ragman
chief foreign affairs commentator for
the Financial Times and whose book most
recent book is called zero-sum world
which I think argues that we are moving
into a zero-sum world